okay so today we're going to talk about
something with not a very exciting name
but basically the way I would I would uh
make your viewers interested is it's a
way of programming the kernel without
programming the kernel
I've heard some people say what
JavaScript is to the web
uh ebpf is to the operating system so
there's a big important distinction in
most modern computers between user space
down here and it's where we spend most
of our prayer time programming and
running applications
and the kernel which is dealt with by
the operating system
and the kernel is doing things like
taking care of the lower level details
of files and
um
making sure that display drivers and
everything run properly one issue comes
if you want to ask questions about say
file access or TCP transfers or things
like that so you want to ask questions
that are
you're interrogating the operating
system to understand you're monitoring
your system
and if you want to ask the question
about say TCP connections or say file IO
and you're writing your monitoring
program you have this great new idea for
how you're going to
stop a distributed denial of service or
something like this but you're writing
it in user space
so you need to ask these questions via
an a p i application program interface
and that limits what you can do and it
puts a bit of a drag on how quickly you
can do it
so if you really
want to know you want to monitor file
access real quickly you want to monitor
TCP connections input output things
using memory or whatever ideally you
want something running up here in the
kernel so ideally
you want your program up here I should
emphasize the kernel isn't magically
faster but for doing accesses on whether
a file is uh being accessed for looking
at things like file read rights TCP in
outs the kernel is much quicker you
don't have to go through this API and
make calls upwards into the kernel
you're already there there's a lot of
problems with that though if you want
that program to reside in the kernel
kernel programming is pretty tricky
and then you say to somebody hey oh I've
written this great new monitoring tool
oh great so what do I do to run your
application
well step one rebuild the kernel of your
computer
so you've already got a big kind of
barrier to entry or let's imagine you're
working on Linux which everybody should
be uh then you'll say uh
dead Airlines 12 hours could you put my
program in your kernel I have been very
good Richard Clegg and hope that he's
going to include it and that maybe takes
a few years
so is there some way we can get little
hooks into the kernel
um and it turns out there's a little
virtual machine in a way I think it's
really badly misnamed now e b p f
extended Berkeley packet filter which is
a really weird name because its Origins
are really strange around about the 90s
early 90s some researchers in Berkeley
about what they call a packet filter
they were networking people
and they were looking at Network traces
and I want some simple way to say
give me all TCP connections to Port 80
or give me all UDP packets please so
they wrote kind of a a regex regular
expression match for Packers right
and I've been aware of this for years
but then a few years ago I started
noticing lots of my networking friends
in conferences they were presenting all
this stuff on Berkeley packet filter I
was like
what's going on here packet filter can't
do that
sometime around about 2014
people came up with an idea though this
packet filter can run in the kernel
maybe you can do clever things in the
kernel and then they started to extend
it and extend it and give it more and
more abilities
um and now it's gone so far away from
being this thing that filters packets
and tells you which packets which match
expression
so now in
um Linux and sort of working in Windows
and I believe a Mac versus on the way
we've got this little virtual machine
sitting in the kernel and do you use a
space can write some code and if it
matches what the virtual machine wants
you can be running little code hooks up
in the kernel
now what's the use of that it means you
can do incredibly quick monitoring or
outputting any kind of drag on the CPU
this thing has even been taken a little
bit further so there is something called
xdf so we have if we have our network
interface card so their packets are
coming in here to be passed up to the
kernel
there's even something called X
d f which will allow these bits of these
BPF programs draw on the interface card
so you're not even taking the burden on
the main parts of your computer now the
burden of computation might be going on
the network interface card
so we've got a way of writing programs
in user space
having parts of the logic the parts of
logic that need to be fast
run on the Kernel or even on the neck
and it's it's just there's an explosion
of monitoring tools so for example one
that loads of you probably use your
Android battery monitoring tool if
you've got a modern version of Android
it's probably running ebpf somewhere in
the mix to look at powered events and
Battery events and stop stop starts with
bits of software and you know sometimes
if you've got an Android phone you'll
get that thing saying application
Facebook is using lots of battery do you
want to stop it that is probably using
ebpf somewhere in the mix on a modern
Android phone I've only just been
learning this so I'm going to show you
the world's worst demo of this because
um I'm I'm not a skilled programmer on
ebpf but what I wanted to do was create
a kind of minimum application for
viewers to see the kind of things that
this can do
but absolutely don't copy what I've done
because it's really bad what I've done
is a little python demo here
um
and
I will say this this is uh this is very
kind of bodged together and the first
thing you'll notice is that this doesn't
look like python because
at the top of the screen here you can
see it defining
BPF Berkeley packet filter text and then
we've got a C program hiding
as a matter of text in our Python
program
so we've got a program here called Don't
Touch dot py it's looking like a c
program at the top here we can see a
little structure that's going to store a
name and the length of it because we're
doing old school C now so we need to say
when we've got a string we need to say
not only the characters but the length
so that's because it's running on the
Kernel it's quite a low level yeah yeah
so these these BPF programs need to be
really low level it's a virtual machine
that's pretty much assembler as I
understand it the EPF hash is a
structure and this line is giving it a
name access it's telling us it's going
to map
this info about names to an integer this
is not the way I should have done it I
have copied this code for a man called
Brendan Greg who's literally written a
book on BPF don't worry too much about
this bit of the code this is just
grabbing the name of a fail being
accessed
so some file is being accessed and here
I'm storing the name of that file
and then
I am storing the name itself so I'm
showing the length of the name and then
the name pushing into my hash
the number one why am I pushing in the
number one because I shouldn't be using
a hash at all to do this I'm just
adapting somebody else's code so I'm
creating a hash map where I should
really do something else but I'm
creating a hash map between the name of
a file that has been accessed and the
number one so every time a file is
accessed this is going to happen
he is the python so here now we're back
in Python land a little bit more
comfortable and this special line says
uh compile me up that text that I was
looking at that BPF program compile it
up and these flags are just going to
stop it spitting a lot of warnings to
the screen
and here's a crucial bit we're going to
attach a kernel level probe to the event
VFS read a read in the file system so
every time a file is read in the file
system we're going to call our little
BPS program and our little BPS program
is going to read and put a name and the
number one into this little hash map
so now whenever a file is read it goes
to flash mapping is associated with the
number one
and yes that is a terribly inefficient
way to do it now we're in proper python
mode and
we're entering a loop
sleeping for a second looking for a
keyboard interfa interrupting casual
Board of the program
and grabbing that table access and that
table is a table of the name of every
file that has been accessed we're going
to look through that table and see if we
can find a file called hands off dot
text
so that's what we're looking for if we
find that file called hands off.txt
we're going to play an alert
and if we've alerted too many times
we're going to exit and that's all we're
going to do and then here while that's
all happened we're going to clear our
list of access to files
so let's see what happens when we run
this program so I'm going to run don't
touch
needs to be run as a root in this case
okay so now the program's running
everyone's second it's looking down the
um list of files accessed and it's
checking whether any of them are called
hands off.txt
now when I access the file hands off.txt
you say oh
it's spotted that I've done that and
it's saying do not look at the file
try again
and it's given me another warning I
asked you not to look at the file and we
can keep on messing about with that and
it will keep on doing that now okay
that's a really really silly silly
example but the original plan I've
adapted that from was looking at the
most accessed files on the system so
instead of just saying is it hands-off
dot text it was
um sorting them all in Python sort them
all out printing them in the table and
showing you a useful monitoring system
with the most accessed files on the
system
now here's the thing if you're going to
run code in the kernel
you have to be pretty sure
that
it's not going to disrupt your machine
running stuff in a kernel is inherently
a little dangerous
so let's try something else let's try
something a bit dumb let's calculate
some Fibonacci numbers so everybody
loves Fibonacci numbers so my kernel
program now is going to calculate some
Fibonacci numbers so I've got a new file
it's almost exactly the same but I'm
going to add in something new into our
structure we're going to add in a 64-bit
Fibonacci number call uh that I'm
calling fib and
I'm doing an iterative calculation of
Fibonacci
now you'll be saying oh hold on Richard
why are you doing that iteratively it's
the classic recursive program I'll come
to that in a minute but iteratively
we're going to go around and we're going
to add together these Fibonacci numbers
first or second the usual way we do it
and return the results so Fibonacci and
and I've got n is 40 which is about what
I can do without an overflow so let me
run that
and we're doing exactly the same thing
for no reason whatsoever we're looking
at the file system we're waiting for the
don't touch this file
and when I press it
instead of just giving me a warning it's
calculated the 40th Fibonacci number
which I can look across and see that
I've got the correct one if I've made it
much higher it would have overflowed
why am I doing this stupid thing because
it is a really Daft thing to do
one one thing is you're putting this
thing into the kernel
what if it stopped running what if it it
didn't come back now you've got a kind
of a rogue process in your kernel uh
that's not great so let's see what
happens if I remove the increment from
that Loop so I've removed the I plus
plus let's imagine I've just messed up
in my programming as happens so often so
now this is not going to terminate I've
written a an unterminating Loop
and now I try and run this
and what is it done we can see
when it's tried to compile the C code
the ebpf compiler has said
um infinite Loop detected
so it's spotted that I'm trying to do
something sneaky I'm trying to get this
to run forever or or I've messed up or
whatever I've done something that's
going to
not fit within the safety parameters of
my kernel and it stopped my code
compiling and that's also the reason I'm
doing a sort of clunky looking iterative
Fibonacci because the usual recursive
Fibonacci another thing that will make
this this computer says no is trying to
do recursion within
um within the virtual machine here so
that's actually really short demo it's
just absolutely a sort of first level
taster
um
but this
um this is used by lots of things now uh
when you look at the companies using
ebpf it's all of the big players it's
Google and Facebook or meta as we're
supposed to call them now and the guy
whose code I I was using Brendan Gregg
is with Netflix so people and um the
people doing the big networking stuff
are all using this and US researchers
are also getting really excited about
this I'll give a particular example
slightly local uh Cambridge York and
bologna have done some work and they're
using this to detect when iot devices
are producing a different traffic
profile than you expect and that might
be a sign of a distributed denial of
service device
so yeah this technology one thing I
would say if you're going to play with
it it's one of those Technologies where
it's at that stage when you read a
manual page you read a Blog and you
think that sounds great I'll implement
it and then you find that that was from
2021 and your operating system is from
2022 so it doesn't quite work anymore so
I would encourage people to have a play
with it but I would also encourage you
to have a little bit of patience so I've
written this for example in a system
called BCC
and then about an hour or two after I
had written it I found somebody saying
BCC is obsolete it's so 2022 so that's
why I call it a rapidly moving Target if
you want to get interested in this
because you're in the kernel yeah is
there a potential here to kind of look
right fry your kind of internal not fry
but no lock up the machine you're
thinking you're thinking of the Halton
cash you know you know it could easily
be it so if if you start running non
terminating Loops in your kernel then
potential potential not great things
will happen which is why it's carefully
protecting foolishness it's trying to
trap it yes I was a bit mystified with
this when I start so
somebody who's looking at my code it
might go Richard what are you doing
you've declared FIB of the function but
you haven't declared n
so if I go u64 am
mysteriously now it lets it compile
which it really shouldn't maybe the devs
could tell me why that is certainly
that's beyond my level of knowledge of
this system
um so you can see a work in progress but
really really important and lots of
production systems are running it
how much room it's got left so now the
sender knows if I don't want to
overwhelm that computer
I'm only going to send he got slightly
dimmer when we got to this road and then
slightly brighter again when we got to
this row and we might find that but
basically if you've got a